凯哥今天很忙
不过今天的话题其实跟投信很有关系
例如CPO这一波投信是有慢慢加码的
那今天盘面上有很多涨的股票是
之前投信爱过但也丢掉了
例如谁呢
例如刚刚讲到的像金像电 金元电 联电
甚至旺系这样的公司
还有就是今天投信高持股的载版股
星星电子被搜索
到底会对载版三雄或是四雄
造成什么样的压力
下个礼拜一我们该怎么办呢
这边就要来请教凯哥了
因为今天星星被搜索
发现投信没跑掉
那会不会礼拜一来补跑呢
我们先一个一个看
麦威尔昨天的财报
结果对于前景的预期
似乎大家不买单
不过今天我们的CPU状况还行
那投信之前错杀的
像联电金像电会回补吗
探针会回补吗
那星星电子怎么办
我刚刚转那边
我刚刚这个
怎么写一个减探针坏
为什么坏
因为减碳其实是这件事情的杀手
我感觉有人利用减掉在做杀手
马贝尔昨天的财报
其实没有讲不好
可是它是跌的
我们可以看到它的重点
其实它昨天的主要会跌的原因就在于
它的营收展望其实没有很好
虽然上调的15亿美元
其实远远的低于市场的预期
因为市场觉得它跟Google
有进行一个投资的一个合作
也认为上应该是要大幅的提升
在这个ASIC的部分
在提升ASIC的部分
但昨天的营收
它调高的理由
主要是来自于这个光学的部分
就是CPO
所以今天其实你看
大部分的细光值
其实都没有什么大跌
都没有什么大跌
联均还涨停
对啊
那我们来看联雅
联雅其实这两天
就在进行一个休息
进行一个休息
但是其实外资还是不离不弃
外賊是不離不棄
好 我覺得凱哥這邊講一句
蠻厲害的
7月24號講的
投信賣了3500多張
今天開始大買
我覺得這地方要往上回走了
這一走走了快九成
是 所以這是給我的獎狀
我們在看CPO確實是
但投信回買是真的
對 因為我們講過嘛
第三季隨著零化音的基板
零化音的基板
開始產能開始出來了
其實大家的業績都會開始上來
所以你看不是聯亞漲
其实像全新也涨
那大家比较关注的是
马肥尔涨的这么不差
那股价是下跌的
可是跟他关系最紧密的是
滑星光
他也没有什么跌啊
你看投薪是不是
最近是不是积极的在买
很红场
对啊
因为他就是有数字嘛
确实他的EP的数字
确实是漂亮的
那你看买卖超的部分
基本上是18000多张
对7000多张
但是形态上来看
他确实这边
还有一点点的压力
還有一點點的壓力
剛好碰到
對 還有一點壓力
但是其實以日線來看
其實就已經在創新高了
但是州的角度
其實還有一點點
需要繼續的努力
但是跟Maveo
基本上沒有什麼太大影響
Maveo有什麼太大影響
CPU是投信愛的
這邊就是投信
猶豫的
投信之前殺過的
這個總統講的國劇
聯電 日月光投控
台達 核生堂 金像電
後面的你比較喜歡
怎麼投信殺的都沒有殺下去
還拉起來
那就表示投信是殺錯了
那我們來看一下
其中比較特殊的就是聯電這真的很多人關心對 因為我當時讲过就是联电它有一个什么细电容的部分细电容的部分我那时候就直接讲了
就是它有细电容
虽然那时候大家都在讲利基电
是
我说它有点被杀的有点冤枉
冤枉
那今天外资就回来买
这个真的很猛
外资回来买了8万多张
今天头信就稍微买得比较少
所以就拉上来
没有买还卖
拉上来
但是你看
它这一根的量其实蛮大根的
是
这根的量其实远远超过这根
所以看起来这里震荡完之后
还会再往上走
那如果以周的形态来讲
它也还只是一个反弹
还没有构成所谓的直接的V转
还没有构成
为什么
因为这边确实张数差太多了
买卖超的张数
18万张对56万张
所以我觉得它只是让它稍微怎么样
深渊
但是还没有到说
可以让它直接坐到店上
直接當官的位置
是
對 接著看金像店
好
金像店
基本上我們之前也有來賓
不離不棄
金像鏈
本節目對金像鏈
確實不離不棄
他業績不錯
對 你看今天投信
就開始回來買了
投信開始認錯
認錯 就是投信開始會回來買
之前他殺的股票
今天土洋同賣
對 他會回來買
他之前殺的股票
因為其實這些股票
不是他不愛
而是我那時候講過
他們氣小就大
是 有沒有
我說他們是小的電子股
買大的
買大型圈子股
所以你看他現在就開始回來買
而形態上來講
他目前的大量高在這裡
是
我就突破了
而且你看從州的角度來看
就更明顯了
州的部分也是突破大量高
所以看起來
他就持續往上漲
遊戲了
持續往上漲
接下來看的是國聚
國聚今天雖然投信還在賣
土洋同賣
國聚投信還在賣
我多辛苦
但是因為今天有指標股往上拉
剛剛我們總統有講
今天像和聲堂
新倉店都拉起來了
對不對 小弟都拉起來了
大哥再怎麼艱困
也要想辦法醒過來
基本上也不用太難過
你看這也很離譜
賣了12萬張
只是買了2萬多張
所以他還在泥澡中
慢慢要爬起來
我看到有人在問說
會不會回到1000
先不要想1000
先反攻再說
對 因為我覺得9月
是他們一個反攻的契機
反共有契機
再來就是我剛剛講
這個減掉真快
今天的一點多
兩個副總一個會計被帶回
傳出的訊息
所以它是沙尾盤
從這邊跳水
而且投信來不及走
因為一點多
大部分同志經理人
不是在休息就是在吃飯
這是你在投信的心得嗎
因為投信
他們大部分是開盤前單
對啦
他不會在盤中突然下單
盤中突然下單
是有緊急的事情
像這個確實是有符合
要緊急下單
可是因為他們在外面
所以還不急回來
再來就是
因為他傳出的事情
大家第一想法就是
他不是優等生嗎
對啊 資優生啊
對啊 他是優等生啊
會有什麼大事呢
但是你看到今天
下午就很多內幕就跑出來了
但我覺得很奇怪
就是現在還在檢調的調查當中
檢調不公開
為什麼會有這些東西出來
好 有聽到很多說法嗎
第一個當然大家會
立刻想到內線交易
第二個說人家的產品
什麼洗產地
我想凱哥都看完了
你覺得可能性呢
我覺得我要替他講一句話
什麼
就是第一個是
星星本身
他也有大陸廠對那洗什麼產地呢那星星大陸做的不能嗎是可以唯一的可能就是他星星大陸的產地出來他是不是這個材料上面
是寫Made in China
還是直接就打Made in Taiwan
我覺得這個可能有一點點的瑕疵
但是其實公司下午就有發新聞稿了
他說對業績 對財務沒有影響
公司發的新聞稿是說
目前一切營運正常
對
對 那它會這樣子寫
我覺得比較大的問題
會出現在投信
因為我剛剛講的
它是優等生
你這樣被寫出來表示什麼
表示你的內控有問題
他昨天才創歷史新高
今天也有創喔
對 表示你的內控有問題
那問題造成投信會怎樣
會不敢再買它啦
好 至少會不敢再買
但是對整個ABF族群
我個人覺得沒有影響
真的喔 因為現在已經有人穿
會不會景碩也會被插
會不會南電也被查
不是啊
因為景碩 新興 南電
他們在大陸都有廠啊
雖然他們大陸廠多的東西
你說他們就是洗產地
會不會太誇張了吧
而且你要知道
這麼高階的ABF
目前大陸是沒有能力做得出來的
你就想這件事情就懂了
所以我覺得
講洗產地這有點在
刻意的要模糊焦點
模糊焦點
然後再來今天又傳出什麼
內線交易
對
因為這個台灣史上還蠻多的
然後又講說
它涉及什麼農工農的法規
對 所以我覺得它有點怪
有點怪
但我個人就覺得
基本上投信會是比較大的問題
因為投信買很多了
所以投信只要稍微剪碼
就會讓它下來
好 我們來看一下
今天的形態
對
距離這個低點
有一點點的危險
因為今天盤中有稍微拉起來
可是大家沒有想到的是
這個新聞故意做很大
對 它跟一般的檢調搜索不太一樣
是 對
我個人覺得啦
如果是個人一般檢調搜索
如果是搜索主力
對
不搜索公司
那可能就是一天的反應
可是它是搜索公司
而且還帶走了
連名副總
我覺得這影響就會比較大一點
而且我會覺得涉及的就是
我剛剛講的公司治理
公司治理的問題
所以我覺得
可能
APF不會大跌
但是星星跑不掉
再劫難逃
再结难逃
那手上有的朋友
好 那我们来看一下
怎么办
我觉得他可能会先跌到这里
哪里
哇塞不得了
大概在900到1000的附近
也就是说会跌到两三根
所以我觉得礼拜一有
还是要先减码一点
虽然外资还在买
对
外资还在买
因为今天尾盘还勾起来
对
但我觉得礼拜一跌一定是难免
而且其实公司在第一时间
也很难去解释得非常的清楚
因為畢竟它不是只帶走一名會計
而是帶走兩名副總
那你說這中間會不會查查查
查出來什麼內線交易
這就很難講
因為有些公司是不能查
進不起查
因為這個內線的事情
其實是比較容易被查到的
那大家要轉戰景碩或南電嗎
我個人覺得
因為大家之前都覺得
景碩是拿最佳進步獎
就是它就是60分
對 然後呢這個信心呢是90分
是 對
那一個90分一個60分
那現在這90分的不能買
你就可能只能回來買60分
是
因為投信最近確實也開始在青睞景碩沒錯對 那你剛好就讓他一個理由就說 那我就把索數再加滿再加滿這是有可能的接著沒來講說
在這波行情裡面
其實台股莫名其妙
已經有這麼多的股票
都在五千塊以上
五千 還不是一千
五千塊以上
五千
這台股史上難見的一個局面
對 在那麼多五千的公司裡面
居然有一個族群
有三家公司
對 三家
這不是一個集團
是族群
是一個族群
長成一個五千族群
其實不太容易
所以我們今天就來看一下
看一下
那這個立基裡面
其實我們大致來看
這個旺系 隱威跟這個宏鏡
對 他們其實在碳這裡面
可以這樣一分為二
這是前段
這是後段
對 這是在碳
整個晶圓還沒有上線之前
先做的檢測
股價來講看起來它有點委屈
對
但是如果就目前股價的位置
是
它跟它比較有搞頭
比較有機會
我們等一下來講一下
好 這是紅鏡
因為紅鏡跟那個建測
是同樣的東西
是 對
也就是建測如果好
理論上紅鏡就要跟著好
建測最近很好勒
對 最近建設很好
所以建設很好
為什麼宏進沒有很好
好 我們來看
宏進的大量的位置在這裡
當然位置在這裡
所以它已經在大量的下緣之上
所以它只差這裡沒有站上而已
所以它是很有機會的
那今天整理完之後怎麼樣
就會開始往上走
因為我想說
金冊已經往上走了
都在反映第四季到明年
它應該也要往上走
接著是日線來看
日限的大量在這裡
它也是站上的
只是離日的大量高有一段距離
投信在賣
可是外資在賣
外資在賣
而且你看
買賣超其實是
買方略大於賣方
所以我覺得宏晉
還有機會再上一層樓
而且現在這個位置
離它的新高
還有一段距離
我覺得這個是不錯的
接下來要看到旺系
旺系最近就比較慘
因為最近投信拼命賣
拼命賣
我們之前講過
它的第二件第三季有点错字
所以市场有点不认同
周线它有点压力
为什么
因为这一根的大量D在这里
对
大量D在这里
所以你看它要站上这里
整理完之后再往上
但是你可以看到
投信在卖
可是外资怎样
已经开始回来买了
开始回来买了
那因为它就是很多的ETF都有
对
所以我觉得要杀
就是大家一起跟着杀
但是只要
这个多空力道开始扭转之后
他們就會覺得說
我賣錯了 我又不賣了
他就會開始往上爬
所以我覺得有點忘記是被挫殺
也是可以留意
所謂的被挫殺當然就是賣了之後
股價繼續往上
就只能說是被挫殺了
那現在的話
投信當然目前看來是把它賣下去了
能不能夠直穩讓投信買回來
就值得觀察
那因為現在千金股
5塊錢一跳改成1塊錢一跳了
以後零股呢
12月7號開始
也要從9點
對不對 就可以交易了
所以其實對於這種五千塊
大家不要壓力那麼大
都可以試試看
對 我覺得他可以看
你就是看
輝達其實對明年展望是很樂觀的
明年是70%的增長
70%的增長
對他而言就是大補完
對 所以我覺得他還是會過高的
是 好啊
這麼有信心
非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝趙華